i love seeing this guy and the success
that he has had i
met him for the first time when he was a
member of i think it was the vikings
he'd not even yet been on the lines and
he would come in and hang out on nfl
total access and show off his
broadcasting shops that now
is shown on sports and entertainment
shows not just
good morning football but also the nfl
today on cbs
and also i don't want to mess up the
entertainment uh
outfit that he's part of as well but uh
he's nate burleson on the rich hazard
show which one is it uh
nate extra you're an extra man correct
yep that's right it's extra
entertainment
and i must admit that winston to watson
winston to watson it was very confusing
and i felt so bad because i'm the one
sitting next to joe thomas
and he's the one who's never done it
before and i'm like just take it one
snap at a time and i'm the idiot
standing to his left calling the game
and botching names left and right last
year but it was a great broadcast
nonetheless
i thought it was a great time nate
working with you last year like we did
it really was and i i enjoy um being
able to hang out with you
not just personally but professionally
and sharing the booth which it's funny
though because
as we were criticizing james winston
like every tampa bay buccaneers fan and
all the sports fans saying oh here's
james again throwing a pick six
only if we had a quarterback i mean a
good quarterback a veteran quarterback
maybe a legend
somebody that doesn't throw pick sixes
and they signed tom
brady and since since that time when we
were in the booth together
i believe tom brady has thrown two pick
sixes if we include
the postseason against the titans and
then
of course earlier this year yes indeed
and he actually threw one
last week also in a win you know so
he's done it a couple of times now
though we're sitting here
talking about last night's game do you
think nate
and all the football that you have
played and observed and talked about
that brady did in fact lose track of the
downs
last night i believe he did i'm not
going to try to cover up for brady
um you know anytime you look at the ref
and you
give him those eyes with four fingers up
asking
as if you know you you you think that
there's another down and i
i saw i saw a tweet and eisen don't get
mad at me
but i saw a tweet somebody said it must
be a michigan thing and it was a side by
side with him and whatever
i didn't agree
you're just letting me know that we're
lockstep on that front that you
also did not like it but you'd like to
talk about it i like it but you're right
that
that indication of four fingers up in
the air is not like so the bears are
four and one now right
i mean like that that would definitely
lead to something
but but the greater the greater issue
again is that
um you know that yes even if brady did
lose track of downs or something like
that
is that it's kind of the cherry on top
of the
the the lack of discipline or
situational
smarts that sometimes this team
displayed last night and that
fact that brady uh committed that means
that this team is still
not yet uh on the same page as we'd like
to say in the nfl
what do you think about the three and
two bucks now after what you saw last
night nate burleson
it's such a strong contrast between what
was last week
in the five touchdown game and then also
you know
what we've seen early on in the season
we were talking about it on good morning
football
and the question was as the tampa bay
buccaneers hit their stride and i wanted
to say yes
but given the fact that you had a hobble
mike evans out there
you have chris godwin who was one of the
premier wide receivers in the league
on the sideline and still gronk trying
to find some type of rhythm out there
within this offense
i have to answer no they haven't hit
their stride i think there's a bigger
question is
did this off season with quarantine and
not being able to
be in the same building study inside the
football classroom
did that play a role in tom brady not
being as prepared as he typically is
because we know tom brady is a student
of the game
but as we see with the mental errors and
also the mistakes
um not not necessarily the mistakes but
the injuries
that we've seen in football i think the
off-season or the lack thereof
has played a crucial part in some of
these teams stubbing their toe
figuratively and literally with some of
these injuries but
i do feel like tom brady and the bucks
they're a decent team
you know it's it's rare that we talk
about tom brady and any teams eddie on
and saying that they're decent but
i'm not going to bs you and say oh
they're great and they're perfectly fine
no they're not
they're not perfectly fine and given the
fact that this quarterback is in his mid
40s there's never been a threat to run
in the pocket
and you see he does not want to get hit
and anytime there is a collapse of the
pocket like we saw last night
khalil mack being an absolute monster
yes i believe that
it's going to be it's going to be
trouble for those guys for any defense
that can collapse the pockets on brady
and uh
and make those windows very small so now
that we're one game into the second
quarter of this
season the best team in the nfc is fill
in the blank sir
what do you got the seattle seahawks
you know i i feel like the best
quarterback in the nfl is this year
is uh russell wilson the best team is
the seattle seahawks i mean
you get jamal adams back him along with
bobby wagner and then that front
tell me another defense that is as scary
as that and then offensively
dk metcalf has arrived folks i mean this
isn't your oh he's pretty good
this second year wide receiver is he's
going to be decent and he's going to
have a
good career no this dude if he continues
to trend in the right direction
as i see him in he's going to be
mentioned as the best receiver in the
game in a matter of two years or less
and then he's complimented by tyler
lockett and luckily luckily
chris carson wasn't too injured with
that egregious gator
role that was done in that cowboys game
but he's back in the fold
so you add all of those elements seems
like they have everything
um so i do feel like the best team in
the nfc is the seattle well another
uh player who's gonna hope to follow in
your footsteps and i think he will
from the nfl to an outstanding
broadcasting career nate is greg olson
who prior to the um season came on this
show
and i asked him his impressions of
seeing dk metcalf
up and close and personal he said he's
got calvin johnson
type ability you are somebody who would
know
uh based on what you're seeing if if
that is something similar what do you
think about that it's a very
very high standard to reach but what do
you think
nate no doubt about it that that's high
praise but
you know when it comes to calvin i
remember the first time i saw him
and i just signed the detroit lions and
i'm sitting back i'm going through
practice i get in the locker room and
i'm kind of in awe you know i'm a fan
of just real talent and i'm not going to
be the guy to front
and act like i'm on the same level
certain dudes that i'm in of
right happened with randy moss and then
it happened when i signed with the
detroit lions
now getting the locker room at the
practice and the media storms my locker
and they're just talking about me
signing there and why i signed with the
detroit lions
um and the next question was well well
listen you played with randy moss
and and you were on the field with
calvin today you know we've had some
trouble with number one wide receivers
you know we had roy williams and charles
rodgers rest in peace uh because he
passed away
you know is calvin the guy i mean what
do you see out of calvin
i mean do you think that he can really
hold down this organization as a white
out i'm talking about a true number one
and i'm sitting back and i wanted to
give him that
james harden roll my eyes walk away from
the interview face
cause i'm like what dude are you guys
looking at
you've been here since he's been drafted
i spent 24 hours here in detroit i
haven't even unpacked my bags and i can
already tell this dude is the best wide
receiver in the game
and that's kind of what i said and they
were like okay you know we'll see
kind of thing and sure enough within a
couple of years calvin johnson broke
jerry rice's record and was the most
unstoppable force so for greg
said who's been around the game and has
seen pure talent
for him to say that i mean i i agree
with him 100 percent
dk has all of it he's built like david
boston
he can run routes like julio jones and
he's starting to develop these soft
hands like
larry fitzgerald i mean that's one hell
of a combination oh and not to mention
he's playing with russell wilson that's
right he could be the coolest
quarterback to ever catch a ball from
because he's just like a big brother
that wants to see his little brother win
and he also throws a great ball too
right i mean i think he and
probably here i think he and aaron
rodgers throw
a deep ball where it seems like it drops
straight down a chimney like it
literally
comes straight down like on a
right at you and it just puts it right
there it's a perfect combination so
that's why
obviously seattle is going to be tough
to beat and then in the afc the team
that has the best
chance to knock off the chiefs after
through four weeks
would be which team nate burleson which
one
you know i i so desperately want to save
the ravens
and if i do people will sit back and say
hey when you saw the game
that that was a struggle for lamar in
that office and it was i'm not going to
sit in front
but i will say this and this is in me
being apologist for
the baltimore ravens or even lamar
jackson and some early drops in that
game
and you have some early drops in the
game versus the chiefs that's like
playing against the the kevin durant
golden state warriors with steph curry
and klay thompson
and missing five threes in a row and on
the other end of the court their
fast-paced transition offense
they bust down those five threes they
open up games quickly i say that to say
this
it's the same things facing the chiefs
if you have a couple of mistakes if you
drop a ball if you give up a big play
and then you don't counter back
they're going to open up the game and
they'll have control of it i mean with
the
ability of padma to discernment with the
ball because he's not going to throw the
game away
and then the game plan of andy reid and
eric the enemy
like it's just tough to beat those guys
um you know i don't want to i throw in a
random it's not so random but i'll throw
in a
a team that as of this week they
wouldn't come to mind because of how
they got smacked around
um the patriots i do feel like we got
cheated
um you know and and 2020 has been
exactly that covet 19 the coronavirus
has
has done everything from hurt our loved
ones with all the
the deaths that we've seen around the
globe put people in vines financially
it has our kids sitting out of school
doing everything virtually
but in the in the world of football
because i want to mention those things
first so i wasn't insensitive to what
the real issues are
but in the world of football um i feel
like corona cheated us out of
a really good matchup i mean you know
cam newton
in the new patriots offense versus
the kansas city chiefs like that would
have been interesting to watch and i'm
not sitting here claiming that
cam newton would have just ran through
the chiefs but i mean
literally he could have ran through the
chiefs because that offense is different
the the the patriots team that that
put the chiefs in a bind and and pat
mahomes struggled against
cam was running that exact offense but
he had the ability to use his legs which
makes that offense so much more
dangerous so
uh i would like to see that at some
point that's if the patriots season
doesn't fall apart because of
what just happened with cam newton being
benched and all the guys that have
already opted out of the season
um but yeah that's the team that comes
to mind because i was really excited
about what cam was doing in that
patriots uh offense me too what about
the bills
i mean i i kind of think that they have
a quarterback that can do it again
arm legs defense that can maybe get in
mahomes grill
uh obviously it's not belichick
coordinating it but
they sti it's no slouch with leslie
frazier
and they also have playmakers
now with digs in that mix i mean i
i i know that alan it's only just four
games but he looks
the most valuable part uh in that regard
too
what about buffalo nate yeah he he is uh
the most valuable part i mean he's mvp
you can either call him the most
valuable part or even the most valuable
player in the league
you need to be in the conversation too
yes i i i mentioned
i mentioned russell wilson in in aaron
rodgers in that conversation
cam for a quick second was even in it
and josh allen
should definitely be in the conversation
as mvp
he starts off the season and he sets a
career high in past yards
and then follows that up with a 400 yard
game and you know this is the question
that i posed
to my crew as we were talking about this
on good morning football i said i want
you to
think about josh allen's highlights this
year
just just stop for a second i want you
to think about
a big play from josh allen and i want
you to think about
the highlights from last year what comes
here is him dropping back and throwing
some beautiful balls
and stefan diggs the new piece being on
the other end of those
throws um but last year when you think
about josh allen
it was a combination of both it was him
running around sometimes like a chicken
with his hair
cut off other times running over
linebackers and hurtling over defenders
and doing some very very athletic stuff
but this year
it's almost like he's more comfortable
within the pocket and for anybody that
really wants to
check out the details and the nuances of
watching a quarterback
what makes john challenge so different
and check him out when you watch him
this weekend and moving forward
when he's in that pocket his helmet
doesn't bounce around like a bobble head
some of these rookies some of these
younger quarterbacks when you see these
guys in the pocket
their helmet will bounce around because
it is frantic in their pocket and it is
collapsing
and you're seeing where the coverage is
and trying to figure out where the
pressure's coming from
all the while trying to decipher your
read going from one two maybe even check
down hit my running back
but josh allen doesn't look so panicked
anymore you know what that is one it's
growth
maturity it's knowing the playbook being
surrounded by play makers
but then also in a reference to him
being raised on the cantaloupe farm
it's his cantaloupes dropping man the
dude is turning into a man right before
our eyes
so i i feel like josh allen in that
offense and mcdermott who is in the
running for coach of the year
you got to give them credit no doubt uh
last one for you nate before i let you
go on with your day um
you know the success of good morning
football it was great to hear
uh aikman say during the broadcast last
night um
after joe read a promo for it that he
watches every day so many people watch
every day and
now you you in the nfl today on cbs as
well and extra and you're expanding your
your brand and your world what comes
with that as well is people ripping you
right off what do you say when you hear
toe drag swag being used by others and
you don't get credit for it nate how do
you handle that because i
i always got my catchphrases from
sportscenter ripped straight off and you
know obviously it's the greatest form of
flattery is this imitation but
how do you handle that nate when people
use it and don't give you credit
um well if if it's um
if it's too agree just you know i hit
the lawyer um there was a couple of
brands and i'm talking about some major
brands
that started making some shirts and i
was like oh oh you didn't know i
trademarked this when i played huh
okay i'm gonna send you a quick letter
and um you don't have to holla at me
but um but you know where rich um you
know what it's like
and and i've told you this a thousand
times and i i tell you
whether we're in private over a drink or
um talking in front of the world
um you've been one of the biggest
influences so um you know
we as a as a new generation of
broadcasters and entertainers because
they are synonymous um we're just we're
standing on the shoulders of guys who
have done it before
you from the early nfl network days espn
to the best dance sports show
all the ogs um that haven't played the
game that have played the game
that built really good platforms and you
still doing it with the rich eisen show
um all we're doing is we're trying to
recycle
what has been done before by giving
credit to those who have done it before
us
and then adding a little bit of our own
flavor and the toe jack swag is my own
flavor that's right it is
and i appreciate the the kind words and
sentiments so nate burleson uh
nickname for nate burleson would be
cease and desist it seems
you're just firing that out a little bit
huh cease and desist
so you you you trademarked that when you
were a player you did that
yeah yeah i i did it a couple of times
uh on the sideline
in the end zone i hashtagged it and then
i made a shirt just for me and my boys
to wear around
and once one person said where can i buy
that thinking like a businessman
i immediately trademarked this started
creating shirts and
from from then on um i've been branding
it i did a collaboration partnership
with mitchell ness
and i did a collaboration partnership
with nfl network
and so when it is said or used by any
other network or brand
yes you know you only give them so many
passes before
you go after their and you know what i'm
saying oh i know
they can only do it so much and then you
got to go uh khalil mack on tristan
worfs on them and then that'll be the
end of that
you know then that'll be the end of that
you'll just throw them around uh
nate thanks for the call appreciate it
you take care of yourself you be well
your family anytime man
you got to keep on killing it that's uh
nate burleson of the
nfl today on cbs extra tv and of course
good morning football
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here